this is a production of cornell
university
good morning everyone uh so i direct
cornell's controlled environment
agriculture group which is growing
plants in greenhouses and indoors
so i was curious how many of you
work with growing cannabis products in
greenhouses or indoors in some capacity
by show of hands
okay good so my my talk today will be
most relevant to you if you're growing
in the field and you work with
transplants that you receive this is
also going to be relevant so i was asked
to speak specifically on substrate
testing for soilless hemp
and so that root zone where hemp has
grown either propagating plants or
growing the plants
through till flowering
is very important and you can really
affect the plant health and productivity
through that
root zone
so instead of growing in soil when we're
growing in containers we say that we're
growing in soilless media
or
soilless potting mixes
and the goal of that media is the same
as it is in the soil which is to store
and supply water nutrients and oxygen
to the plant and that oxygen component
is actually really important
roots need oxygen to respire just like
we need oxygen to breathe
and hemp roots are very sensitive to
root diseases if they don't have
sufficient
oxygen
that soil soilless mix that media also
anchors the plant into the container so
they don't flop over and then i'm going
to talk about the important physical and
chemical properties
that you can have tested of your potting
mixes
so just as a introduction the different
soilless media that we have available we
often split those into two groups one
are the organic components and what i
mean by organic in this case is carbon
based so they're typically
plant or animal residues
and coconut core is very common the
shredded husk of coconut that can be
compressed and easy to ship
peat mined
decomposed sphagnum peat moss composted
bark and wood rice hulls biochar and
compost
so those
because they're carbon-based materials
they have a fairly good nutrient holding
capacity as well or cation exchange
capacity is what we talk about
and then we also have inert components
that are not carbon based so those would
be like this this picture on the bottom
right which is stone wall or rock wool
is a spun insulation material
it has very good physical properties
it's good at holding on to water and uh
and
allowing air space but it doesn't have
an additional nutrient holding capacity
so when we're when we're growing plants
in this type of substrate we have to
supply
nutrients every time that we're watering
perlite and vermiculite are other
examples of that as well as lightweight
expanded clay aggregate
so it's important to know the materials
that you're using
you can talk with the manufacturer of
them
to see if they they should do their own
in-house testing for these physical and
chemical properties that i'm about to
talk to
that would be a sign of a reputable
supplier
if they can't provide you with a
nutritional test or information on the
physical properties
you can also
do some of the testing yourself which
i'll talk about and other components you
can you can send to a lab
um so when we're talking about the
physical properties this is the balance
of the
water holding
and
air porosity um and so we when we fill a
container with a mix we have the
substrate itself for the particles
itself
and then we have
space that's not taken up by those
particles and when we water a container
to container capacity that is watering a
complete container fully with water and
allowing it to drip drain
then of those total pore spaces they're
going to be divided into some of those
spaces are still holding air so that's
called the air filled porosity and
that's a percent
by volume and then we have water holding
capacity so those are the pore spaces
that are filled
by water
and so the right soilless media is going
to have a balance between the moisture
holding and the air porosity
and one of the ways that we can think
about that is that water holding
capacity and aeration balance
and the height of the water table in the
pot
is
really only affected by that particle
size where a smaller particle size is
going to be like that container on the
right that holds more water and less air
and if you have a larger particle size
you're going to hold more air and less
water and
often you will see that potting mixes
are formulated to contain
multiple components
so we might have like peat
as well as perlite and vermiculite
because together they they give us the
physical properties that we need their
combined
particle size
balances moisture and air
so the metric that we're really looking
for here
is that the total porosity should be
equal to 50 percent by volume
and then the water holding capacity
within that should be at least 40
percent
and then that means the air porosity
should be at least 10 percent because
air porosity plus water holding equals
total porosity
and where that 10 comes from is in the
traditional greenhouse world not
necessarily the cannabis world but they
found below that 10
there's poorer root growth and not as
enough not enough oxygen for for to
support a really um good robust root
system and where that 40 comes from is
if that the lower that number is the
more frequently you need to irrigate
your container so if you were overhead
watering maybe you would have to water
three times a day if you had really poor
water holding capacity
and just an example of physical
properties of some of the different
sub substrate components that we use
often peat by itself p peat comes in
different layers depending on
how long it's been degrading
and some of the kind of virgin peat
that's toward the top that has been
degraded for a less period of time
actually could serve as a potting mix by
itself um it has sufficient
water holding and it has at least 10
airfield porosity
more often than not we have to add
perlite or vermiculite to peat to
improve its airfield porosity
and then coconut core um is often used
as a material by itself coconut core
also varies in its
how well degraded it is or how how
fibrous it is
but you can find many coconut cores that
by themselves have sufficient air
porosity
um have very good water holding capacity
and interesting in this case it's 95
total porosity so that means when you
buy that coconut coir
you're only getting 5 by volume is
actually that fiber that you're paying
money for and the rest is
is air space or water space
so i'm going to move on to chemical
properties
so ph
really affects the availability of
nutrients in the root zone and it's been
said that about half of the nutrient
disorders that we have um are related to
an improper ph and not due to lack of
the nutrient itself
so this graph shows us availability of
the different nutrients that are
important to the plant as the ph
increases from
four to eight and so with some of the
nutrients like nitrogen and potassium
we're pretty lucky they're actually
widely available
in the root zone across that broad ph
range
and then we have several nutrients like
phosphorus and then all of the
micronutrients iron manganese boron and
so on we're really above a ph of about
six and a half in a soilless media um
those get locked up and are not
available for roots to take up
and one thing about soilless media is
they do have less buffering capacity
than our traditional field soils so with
the field soil we could get away with a
higher ph but in a soilless potting mix
we're really looking for this more
narrow range
on the low end of the spectrum if we
move below a ph of about five and a half
we have issues with calcium and
magnesium availability
and at low ph we can also get too high
of phosphorus solubility that means our
phosphorus can leach out of the
container
too readily
so really the optimal ph we're looking
for for for hemp or cannabis in general
is five and a half to
six and a half um and for monitoring we
we recommend targeting 5.8 to 6.2
um and then if you're say tracking ph uh
every week which i'll talk about
once you track out of that range you
would start taking action so that you
have some time before you get out of
that five and a half six and a half
range
um so there's several factors that
affect root zone ph
and one is the your water source itself
many of our well water sources in new
york are high in their alkalinity
there's limestone deposits um under the
earth um and so the carbonates and
bicarbonates in that water
are like liquid limestone they
essentially increase the ph of our root
zone over time
and so we often see that in western new
york and upstate new york
where our well water is high in
alkalinity and our ph is creeping up
over time
the fertilizers that we use also affect
the ph so a more ammonium or urea based
fertilizer is going to decrease the ph
and a nitrate-based fertilizer increases
the ph so that's actually a tool that we
have to use to adjust ph is adjusting
our fertilizer
and then we can also use acids to to
decrease ph
so i mentioned problems with ph being
too low
which
especially our deficiency of calcium and
magnesium
leaching a phosphorus and if we get very
low sometimes less than like four and a
half or five um
iron and manganese and zinc and copper
become very available to the roots to
take up and we can in some cases see
toxicity of those micronutrients
and then when ph is too high which tends
to be a uh more common problem with the
waters that we have
in uh in upstate new york uh we get
deficiency of those micronutrients iron
manganese and so on and so um
uh this is a photo of iron deficiency
which is uh which affects the upper
leaves the youngest leaves on the plant
um and we get yellowing of those upper
leaves um starting at the base where
they attach to the stem um and then in
particular the veins themselves will
stay green but the intervenal region
will be lighter yellow
the other major chemical property that i
want to talk about is electrical
conductivity
or ec and we use this as an overall
measure of fertility
what it does is it allows us to use a
handheld sensor
to get a measure of the overall salts
that are dissolved in water and it takes
advantage of the property of water that
pure water doesn't conduct electricity
but water with dissolved ions in it
can conduct more electricity
so low ec indicates low overall salts or
low overall fertility and then a high ec
indicates high fertility or overall high
salts
with with hemp and i'll talk about
testing methods but with with the pour
through testing method we're looking for
an ec reading of about 1 to 2.5
depending on the the crop stage
and this is a photo of nitrogen
deficiency which we would get often with
overall low fertility or low ec
which is lower leaf yellowing and small
plant size
um so we're still in our early days of
of knowing exact fertilizer
recommendations for cannabis that's
actually or hemp that's actually one of
the things that i study
but there's there's recommendations
where
we adjust the fertilizer rate often we
talk about the parts per million
nitrogen and then the other nutrients
are adjusted in proportion to that uh
and so at the at the early vegetative
stage um during propagation say we're at
100 to 125 parts per million nitrogen
um during late flowering and or late
vegetative and into peak flowering we'll
be up to about 200 parts per million
nitrogen
and then we'll cut
back down on that about two weeks
before
harvest
so that gives us a target ec of 1 to 1.5
up to 2 to 2.5 during the period when
the plant is using the most fertilizer
um so i want to mention briefly some of
the in-house methods that we have so if
you if you
buy a ph and ec meter for about 200
total um you could do either the pour
through or the one to two dilution
method uh those are those are easy to do
in-house and then laboratories will
usually use the saturated media extract
method
which is a different method
so you can buy handheld ph and ec pens
they'll they'll cost about a hundred
dollars per meter
you want to use a reputable brand some
that i've had good luck with not to
exclude others but are blue lab hanna
instruments and oakton
some are dual purpose so they can
measure both ph and ec
be sure to check the ec unit there are
some different units that are used i
like the ones that measure ec and in um
decisions per meter
instead of ppm
and then the ph meter needs to be
calibrated every day that you use it so
you get a ph4 and a ph 7 reference
solution and it'll take about a minute
to calibrate it before you use it
so for the pour through method which is
the the kind of easiest non-destructive
method you're going to water your plants
about an hour before taking the
measurement so that they can get to
container capacity
um you're then going to place a plastic
saucer under the container
and then depending on the size of the
container you're going to pour a known
amount of
um distilled water on top
and then that's going to push out a
leachate sample so with a six inch pot
we're using about 50 milliliters of
solution
and then you collect that leachate
sample and then that's what you're
putting your your ph and your ec pens
into
and analyzing
with the one to two dilution method or
if you send a sample to a lab for the
saturated media extract method you're
taking slices or core of the media from
where the roots are actively growing so
we find that salts can build up at the
top surface
as well as the bottom and so we want to
take
samples of soil from the middle of the
container where the roots are actively
growing
you would take samples from 10
representative plants pool those samples
together
if you're going to send in a sample to a
lab talk to the lab but they'll usually
require one to two cups of material
and then if you're doing an in-house
test for using the one to two dilution
method um what you're gonna do is um air
dry that sample overnight um compare it
uh combine one part by volume of the
media so often i like using little dixie
cups so three ounce cups so i'll take a
three ounce scoop of that and then two
cups of distilled water
mix thoroughly and let that stand for 30
minutes
and then you can use your ph and ec
meter
to test that water extract
this is also a really good method to use
when testing a new potting mix so if you
don't have the ph and ec information
from the manufacturer you can test a new
potting mix to make sure it's not too
high in salts like some of our compost
based mixes
and it can also tell you about the the
overall fertility
the saturated media extract would be a
method that the laboratory uses um and i
won't go into that that too much but
then typically besides testing ph and ec
they're going to test the individual
nutrients the n p and k and so on
and so it's nice to know what your mix
is at the beginning
and then if you have questions about
fertility over time you can you can send
a media sample into the lab
so this in-house monitoring for ph and
ec really
is most effective if you can do it
weekly
or at least every two weeks and then
graph that over time and track that over
time so here's an example i had plants
growing in containers with a peat
perlite potting mix
we would sample them every seven days or
so
we started taking action when we got
above a ph of six and a half so we
switched to a more acidic fertilizer for
a week
we did that at day 28 and it was
effective
we started getting out of range again
about 20 days later and we switched to
an acidic fertilizer again for for
another week
so overall methodology for correcting
for ph um if your ph is testing high um
the quick method that you have is to do
a one-time drench with acids um either
two ounces of sulfuric acid or three and
a half ounces of phosphoric acid
per 100 gallons of water a lot of
growers will use that through a
fertilizer injector that's say a one to
one hundred injector so then their stock
solution would be two ounces of sulfuric
per one gallon of stock solution and
then that gets diluted down to the
injector to 100 gallons of water gradual
methods to correct for a high ph are to
switch to a more ammonium-based
fertilizer
or if you know that your tap water
source is high in alkalinity is to
continually add
a dilute amount of acid to decrease your
water alkalinity down to 80 parts per
million calcium carbonate
correcting for low ph um which is less
of an issue here i see it more on like
long island for example where they have
very pure water we can use flowable lime
or potassium bicarbonate
you do want to follow very carefully the
label instructions because those
the flowable lime if it's in contact
with the foliage can cause a burn to the
leaf and so you have to go back
afterwards and mist
any material off of leaves if it got on
them and you also want to flush your
your irrigation lines after using those
materials
a more gradual method that we have is to
switch to a more nitrate nitrate-based
fertilizer
and then ec correction so if we have an
eye a high ec
um
that means that we're either over
fertilizing or
our water source or substrate is high in
salts so a quick method is to leach
thoroughly with tap water
and
leech so that we get about a 50 leaching
fraction so about half of the water that
you add to each pot is leaching out of
the bottom
and do that twice and that's going to
reduce the ec by about half
the longer term control would be to
reduce your fertilizer concentration
leech
more frequently with a 20 leaching
fraction so just do that periodically
and then test your water source to see
if it's high in salts or test your
substrate source to see if they're high
in salts to try to identify the cause
correcting a low ec essentially is an
indication that your fertilizer strength
is not high enough so you need to
increase your fertilizer strength or
reduce your leaching fraction if you are
leaching at each irrigation event
with that i just wanted to point out a
few of the commercial testing labs these
will all do
tissue substrate and water analysis the
cost tends to vary from about thirty
dollars um to forty five dollars um and
i find that growers typically once they
find a lab that they that works well for
them
they tend to stick with that lab because
every lab's results will be a little bit
different just kind of funny but
they like if you want to do an apples to
apples comparison you typically stick
with a given lab after a certain point
in time
some of these labs for example i know
for sure that jr peters and macro micro
laboratory
will do
tissue hemp analysis and they have um
sufficiency ranges that that the
laboratory can give you for
what percent nitrogen should be in the
leaves for example based on the stage
that you're at
all right with that i will end and we'll
see if larry gives us any time for
questions
yeah thanks very much neil unfortunately
we're going to try to get back on
schedule
and uh in particular neil did not talk
about all of his expertise in lighting
uh so if you have questions about
lighting also uh catch up with neil he
is an encyclopedia of knowledge so
this has been a production of cornell
university on the web at cornell.edu